we're never as shy and gauche as when
we're attempting to seduce someone we
deeply like the thought of someone this
perfect coming to take an interest in us
seems at once tantalizing and entirely
implausible we develop vertigo and too
often fall behind our insecurities like
two conjoined fears that we are
exceptionally awful and that the beloved
is exceptionally perfect both ideas are
hugely destructive and false however the
road to greater confidence about our own
nature is not to start to tell ourselves
that we are after all brilliant it's to
examine more carefully how brilliant any
other human being can plausibly ever be
and conclude that we are no more awful
than the next soul we're so closely in
contact with our own ridiculous science
we cannot from within if we're halfway
honest have many illusions about
ourselves every day were made aware of
our inherent clumsiness error and
absurdity by contrast we only ever see
that carefully constructed facades of
everyone else which is what can make
them seem quite unfairly more impressive
than they in fact are we shouldn't try
to reassure ourselves of our own dignity
we should grow at peace with the
inevitable nature of our but also
everybody else's ridiculousness we are
idiots now we've been idiots in the past
and we will be idiots again in the
future and that is entirely normal there
aren't any other available options for a
human being once we learn to see
ourselves as already and by nature
foolish it really doesn't matter so much
if we do one more thing that might make
us look a bit stupid the person we try
to kiss could indeed think us ridiculous
but if they did so it wouldn't be news
to us they would only be confirming what
we'd already gracefully accept it in our
hearts long ago that we liked them and
every other person on the earth are
something of a nitwit
the risk of trying and failing would
have it stings substantially removed the
fear of humiliation would no longer
stalk us in the shadows
furthermore it's properly unhelpful ever
to think of someone we want to seduce as
particularly special it's normal of
course to be momentarily dazzled by
beauty or intelligence but we should
quickly recover our poise and remember
that our beloved is after all only human
in other words that behind the alluring
facade once we know them better they
will have a litany of irritating habits
insecurities obsessions and flaws to
give us further confidence if we did
kiss and even want a married this person
will almost certainly be quite unhappy a
lot of the time are intimidated feelings
before a prospective lover stem from a
melodramatic sense of how much is at
stake this paragon will with time prove
to be a lot more complicated than they
appear and will at points be plain
heart-wrenching ly maddening this dark
knowledge should relax us as we
struggled across the room and speak to
them we're not in fact faced with a
divine being and balancing our fate
entirely in their well-formed hands they
are an ordinary creature beset with all
the tensions compromises and blind spots
we know from our own selves someone who
will if everything goes really well in
substantial ways eventually ruin our
lives
we can approach our date with a
down-to-earth confidence of one misery
inducing human reaching out to another
to start a relationship that will in
time at many points feel like an
enormous mistake we can import into the
seduction phase some of the usefully
relaxing ingratitude that we naturally
experienced once a relationship has
started and we can use it to get love
going we should before heading out for
the evening
tell oneself that one is of course
something of a [ __ ] and an imbecile
but then so are they and anyone else we
could meet one or two more acts of folly
should thereafter not seem like they
matter very much at all we publish new
thought-provoking films every week be
sure to subscribe to our Channel and
take a look at more of what we have to
offer at the link on your
dream now